this video is brought to you by
expressvpn hi welcome to another
ColdFusion video this episode is about
two things number one Google one of the
most recognizable brands today we know
them from the operating system on our
phones to their smart home devices to
Google search Google Maps and Gmail and
even YouTube itself they're an
organization that's so prevalent that
they're almost invisible and the other
thing that this episode is about is the
CIA the same organization that
overthrows foreign governments and spies
on leaders and citizens from human
rights violations to drug trafficking
the CIA has always been shrouded in
mystery and controversy so what does
Google have to do with the CIA well many
people may not realize this but the CIA
was directly involved in the foundation
of Google Google co-founder Sergey Brin
even reported to representatives of the
US intelligence community on his
progress not only this but the
application that became Google Earth
originally had CIA investment generally
this is a concerning relationship but in
this episode we're going to take a
deeper look first of all let's take a
brief look at the CIA you are watching
ColdFusion TV
[Music]
after World War two the United States
would face the Soviets in a battle for
world supremacy the invention of the
atomic bomb meant that no weapons could
be fired in this war so other methods
had to be used over the next 40 years a
period known as the Cold War would begin
no shooting just subversive tactics in
the mid 1940s the President of the
United States
inspired by the efforts of the UK's mi6
during World War two would sign the
National Security Act which formed the
Central Intelligence Agency or the CIA
and right away the CIA would get to work
interfering in international politics in
an effort to stave off communist
influence on the global stage the CIA
would interfere with the 1948 Italian
elections they would overthrow the
governments of Iran and Guatemala in
1954 Indonesia in 1957 and Brazil in
1964 the CIA also conducted some rather
questionable projects on their own
people project MKULTRA for example was
the CIA's mind-control program using
quote chemical biological and
Radiological methods many of the studies
within MKULTRA focused on the
administration of LSD to prisoners drug
addicts mental patients along with
government agents and the general public
all without their consent documents
pried loose in 1979 showed that through
a front organization the Central
Intelligence Agency funded what was
called the MKULTRA project the CIA
wanted to understand more about
brainwashing it had money and it was
ready to fund experiments breaking down
the mind with repeated electric shocks
and drugs including massive doses of LSD
these experiments were done without the
informed consent of the patient's lawyer
Allen Stein took up some of the rejected
cases the government's paid a number of
settlements since many of the payments
come with non-disclosure agreements
they're trying to do it quietly it's not
fair I mean I feel I feel blessed that I
was able to get this far for
my parents I I really do that's what
gets me justice I'm just grateful to be
able to do it and I hope you III just
hope that you can hear me up there
because it might bring you peace you
might bring you both peace ultimately
the CIA's goal of using LSD as a mind
the Soviet Union and other enemies never
reach fruition but by the time the
project was dis abandoned in the
mid-1960s hundreds of people were
unknowingly drugged and observed I found
this last one pretty entertaining one of
the most embarrassing failures of the
CIA was the attempted assassination of
Cuba's Fidel Castro so you know in
interviews Fidel Castro used to say if
surviving assassination attempts were an
Olympic sport I would win the gold medal
portably more than 600 attempts over his
50 years in power now many of the failed
plots were concocted by the CIA the CIA
tried infecting Castro's scuba gear with
tuberculosis planting exploding
seashells at his favorite diving site
slipping him a poisoned fountain pen
they even tried poisoning and slipping a
bomb into one of his cigars all of these
attempts were a failure it was a
gigantic waste of time and money in
Fidel Castro was Cuba's dictator for
another forty nine years stepping down
in 2008 only due to failing health this
is all to say the CIA may seem
formidable but when it comes down to it
they're not always perfect with the
Soviet Union gone the CIA s actions
today may be less well known but their
influence in the world certainly hasn't
gone away and that brings us to their
relationship with Google
in 1994 two PhD students Sergey Brin and
Larry Page began working on their
automated web crawling and page ranking
application as part of their research
project they had bet on making the
exploding Internet easy to access and it
paid off
enormous Lee Sergey Brin's part of the
Stanford Research was funded by the NSA
and CIA Brin would often report progress
to non Stanford individuals one of whom
was dr. Rick Stein Hauser Steinhauser
represented the CIA's office for
research and development to oversee
their research funding in a joint CIA
NSA program it wasn't uncommon at the
time for research projects to be funded
by the intelligence community government
intelligence agencies had set up
programs and often seed funded projects
roughly three to four million dollars of
funding flowed through the intelligence
community programs into universities and
while both Google and the intelligence
community deny that the CIA directly
funded the start of Google it's evident
that the intelligence community's
research funding helped not only Google
but Silicon Valley as a whole there are
many ways this relationship is built and
preserved one of the biggest is perhaps
the Hyland's forum there's a good chance
that you've never heard of this forum
but it connects the wider Department of
Defense and the intelligence community
to the tech startups this keeps the
military and the intelligence community
at the cutting edge of tech many
executives on the Highland forum hold
positions in the CIA NSA and many other
agencies movements from these agencies
into Silicon Valley is common for
example in 2012 the Highland co-chair
who also worked at DARPA left the agency
to accept a senior executive position at
Google in an email thread made public
Sergey Brin discussed information
sharing for the purposes of national
security with the head of the NSA
in 1999 at the peak of the dot-com boom
the CIA launched in coutelle a Silicon
Valley venture capital fund its mission
was to invest in startups that aligned
with intelligence agencies needs in 2003
the CIA through Inc Utah would invest in
keyhole keyhole was a startup that built
3d global mapping software one of its
first uses was to support US troops
during Operation Iraqi Freedom the
campaign to overthrow Saddam Hussein the
next year
Google bought keyhole whose team now
included CIA personnel Google would soon
turn keyhole into the basis for Google
Earth only a year after the purchase the
director responsible for initially
investing in keyhole at the CIA
investing firm in-q-tel moved to take a
position at Google during this period
Google would win contracts for different
search applications for the NSA and CIA
it's understandable that Google has a
relationship with the CIA and many other
government agencies in fact most tech
giant's do at the start of this year
with a looming us election some of the
biggest names such as Microsoft Facebook
Twitter and Google have had meetings
with the FBI Homeland Security and the
Office of the Director of National
Security little is known about these
meetings apart from the theme of how
tech giant's can ensure security for the
2020 elections Google for example has
implemented an advanced protection
program this program offers Google's
highest protection level to high-risk
targets such as journalists activists
politicians and business leaders it
effectively makes these accounts less
susceptible to hacking risks such as
phishing and malware attacks but perhaps
the greatest demonstration of the
company's integration into the
intelligence community is Google federal
Google federal was launched in 2006 and
its purpose is to serve federal
contracts at a certain point this branch
of Google had so many former NSA staff
that they became known as the NSA West
and it's very launch google federal went
on a hiring spree hiring managers and
salespeople from the Army Air Force CIA
Raytheon and Lockheed Martin it added to
its lobbying prowess by assembling a
team of Democratic and Republican
operatives the strength of the
relationship between Google and the
intelligence community was graphically
highlighted in 2010 at this time Google
came under attack from what was believed
to be Chinese government hackers the NSA
came to Google's aid the two
organizations struck up a deal an
exchange of information
according to journalists quote Google
agreed to provide information about
traffic on its networks in exchange for
the intelligence from the NSA about what
it knew your foreign hackers Google
jigsaw is a division dedicated to
combating global threats such as
extremism censorship and disinformation
but this division has had its missteps
in 2012 as the Syrian civil war was
escalating the intelligence community
was pushing for a change of government
in 2016 leaked emails revealed that
Google's jigsaw Department brainstormed
ways that it could push Bashar al Assad
from power among these ideas was a tool
that visually mapped and tracked
officials he broke allegiance to Assad's
government
Jared Kohan head of Google jigsaw
planned to show this data on TV networks
such as al-jazeera within Syria the
purpose of this was to serve as
propaganda to give confidence to the
opposition of Assad this opposition was
of course the side that the intelligence
community wanted to win according to
Fred Burton a former intelligence agent
at the security branch of the State
Department quote Google is getting White
House and State Department support and
air cover in reality they are doing
things the CIA cannot do
more recently Google created a tool to
track if users are at high risk of
radicalization based upon their internet
usage the tool redirects them to
government websites focused on
persuading them off their ideas it seems
now more than ever Google and other tech
giants are blurring the line between
corporate and government intelligence
Google's entry into the market makes
financial sense but 2019
the federal government was spending
ninety billion dollars a year on
information technology it's a huge
market and Google seems to want to
maintain a strong presence the world in
which the CIA and the intelligence
community operates is a distant cry from
reality and what most people are aware
of likely we will never know the full
extent of their operations or the events
that the CIA had an impact on from
helping overthrow governments to spying
on the public many controversies follow
this organization we didn't even touch
on drug trafficking operations during
wartime in Asia
Watergate or the recruitment of former
Nazis that being said it could be argued
that there are just as many less
sensationalized activities that have
kept peace in the world that the public
would never be aware of such is the
nature of this organizations work
secretive agentic as technology and the
freedom of information give power to the
masses there is now a rising risk of an
adverse technocracy what hand will tech
giants play in this feature and what
does this mean for the world and society
if private companies begin running
intelligence and intervention programs
on the public many years ago when I was
younger I used to be fond of Google but
now I look at them differently
thanks to expressvpn for sponsoring this
video I've become more aware of
protecting my online privacy as time has
gone on lately I've been using
expressvpn as it's one of the best ways
to do that you can choose between one of
3000 servers around the world to have
your data routed through this hides your
IP allowing you to browse the web
anonymously another benefit is that you
can watch content that may be blocked in
your country for example if I wanted to
watch the movie Xmas you know on Netflix
it's blocked in Australia where I live I
can just turn on expressvpn set it to
the United States and I'm good to go you
can get three months of expressvpn by
clicking the link in the description
below so thanks for watching this video
I hope you did get something out of it
it's a bit disconcerting but I think
it's better that people are aware of
this kind of thing so for those who are
interested in videos kind of like this
I've done an episode on how governments
hack each other another episode on the
dark web and one more on WikiLeaks so
thanks for watching my name is - gogo
and you've been watching cold fusion and
I'll catch you again soon for the next
video cheers guys have a good one
cold fusion if you thinking
[Music]